plasticity is an organism's ability to
change its traits in real time so during
its own lifetime in response to specific
environmental conditions for example
when you lift weights you grow bigger
muscles when a person goes out in the
sun their skin can tan developmental
plasticity is when an organism changes
how it grows or develops according to
environmental conditions the article
talks a lot about plasticity in ppis
fish this is a group of fish still allow
today that have well-developed gills and
lungs if raised in a tank full of water
their lungs stay small their fins stay
fishlike if however they are removed and
raised on land as they struggle to pull
themselves Against Gravity fin muscles
strengthen as you might expect but also
bones of the fins change shape and do so
in a way that makes them measurably
better at Floppy Fish walking